Daniel I want to know what you're
thinking about some of the new stuff
coming our way the Mandalorian because
you know we were we were all expecting
maybe Boba Fett to have something to do
with I don't know a feature film or have
some sort of involvement in that show so
what is it you think about the show and
what it turned out to be that made that
the right path for Star Wars on TV well
you could understand the character Boba
Fett wasn't force-fed on every single
moment and every single scene of Star
Wars and we can't just come and redo
that and then take that all away
right away the Mandalorian for me being
raised in the convention world the 500
first have had a really great response
to the Lucasfilm and and the respect
that they have given as fans to the
company Mandalorian mercs I was I think
the first the one of the first people as
an honorary member and I was very
honoured you know there's all of like
maybe 50 members 15 years ago and
they've worked and worked and worked to
establish not only the name as the
Mandalorian mercs but as a fan group and
a big lovers of not just Boba Fett the
character but the Mandalorians and the
Mendel learns that he came from and he
worshiped and he wanted to obviously
represent so for that now that the
Mandalorians have a place that we can
explore you start to understand why the
Fett started to be attracted to that
Mandalorian lifestyle why they dressed
as the Mandalorians and took on that you
know homage I guess but decreed but the
Mandalorian doesn't have to be the
Mandalorian and have Boba Fett in every
single episode I think the fact is is
with all the new directors and
everything like that and exploring the
world of the Mandalorian you guys are
going to get so much that we weren't
promised unfortunately from my god
George Lucas he said all right I'm gonna
do six and I'm down and he gave you one
more which was the Clone Wars
to the holiday special but you guys got
the Clone Wars with the birth of Boba
Fett is the holiday special so yeah
that's why I love them I love the
holiday special I wanted to build one I
told everybody about the holiday special
then everyone else started building it
before me I'm an idiot
what you just said though is one of the
coolest things about Star Wars world
building is that maybe Boba Fett isn't
front and center like some have hoped in
the Mandalorian but by exploring
Mandalorian culture in that then we can
go back and watch Boba Fett and other
pieces of material and have more depth
and layers to him which is the coolest
thing and with Disney I think that
they're understanding that they have to
make long charity out of it because
there's generations after generations
you guys have done it to them you bridge
your kids to love Star Wars too and
these kids are gonna breed their kids
the left Style Wars 2 so you can't blame
them so now I think it's just about
figuring out what the fans want how to
cater to that but also stay true to the
storylines and their backstories that we
once had as well